okay so if I can give one word of advice
other than don't have too much faith in
Michael Bay and if a girl looks 21 and
claims to be 18 she's probably very
illegal it would be never get
tonsillitis ever
it truly sucks ass and because
tonsillitis feels like getting throat
by Satan who's using cerberus is
spiked strap-on I'm going in to get my
tonsils taken out today yeah by the time
you watch this I'll probably resemble
Hasselhoff and all his dignity I lack
thereof
I think it's funny people are always
like yeah get to eat all the ice cream
you want it's awesome but I was like I'm
an adult man I can eat whatever I want
whenever I want I can live on a strict
diet of Cinnabons 24/7 for the eight and
a half weeks before certain cardiac
arrest so the whole ice cream thing
kinda ceases to be the whole silver
lining in the adult world vicodin no
always fun but I'm ultimately telling
you this because the doctors claim I'm
gonna be out of commission for like two
weeks doctors but I'm pretty certain I
will not be able to do a movie review
this weekend I mean pessimistically I'll
be back in action to review Iron Man 2
on the 7th optimistically I'm really
gonna push to be back in action for
Nightmare on Elm Street on the 30th not
quite sure the recovery time because
I've just never had my tonsils out
before but I do have videos that I'm
gonna release throughout my recovery to
hold you guys over I swear you won't
even know I'm in a chemical coma from
cough syrup and narcotics so today's the
20th and assuming that I'm going to be
back in action on the 30th I will upload
a video every other day from now until
the 30th that's right it'll be that 10
day every other day extravaganza awesome
I did just make that up so starting now
every 2 days for 10 days check YouTube
and you'll have a new video from me my
gift to you
ultimately is because if you guys are
like me you hate being bored I just
don't want to bore you and how can I
film videos when I can't talk you ask
because I've already filmed them so just
bear with me enjoy hopefully the laughs
in the meantime and I'll be back doing
movie reviews by Ironman hopefully
Freddy and remember never ever get
tonsillitis so please guys and gals I'm
off to experience a lot of pain
anesthesia and pills every 2 days be
here